[Music]
one of the most difficult things that we
struggle with is regular maintenance on
equipment and as we're kind of winding
down getting to the end of the season
and have more free time the equipment
comes home from jobs and we've got
opportunities to do regular maintenance
well it's not regular this would be
seasonal maintenance so some of those
things
include changing oil transmission
hydraulic fluids tightening tracks some
of those things that that throughout the
work season that maybe we didn't get to
or that we didn't give enough
attention some of the other things that
we've done this year is is new teeth on
the buckets new cutting edges on the
excavator buckets um we've got that 6t
grading bucket and we've got a rock
bucket here that we put new teeth on
and it's it's you can get a lot of wear
out of those teeth you can run them
right down to to to the nub right down
to nothing but we found that they cut a
lot better they work a lot better when
they're sharp and so it's worth that
additional money of changing the teeth
regularly to to have that machine
working as efficiently as
possible so again that's just some of
the the annual maintenance that we do
that's in addition to regular
maintenance like greasing and oiling and
oil oil changes and those types of
things that may be more regular on the
schedule but it's it's a full-time job
trying to to keep up on the
maintenance in addition to get the work
done and keep projects moving forward
[Music]
throughout the
year there are certain projects like if
we've got a big road building project
then we'll we'll make upgrades to
equipment that maybe hasn't gotten
upgrades in a few years this year here
we put new tires on the road grader
because we had we had a couple of miles
of road to build and we were going to be
working the heck out of that road grader
and it needed some new tires I couldn't
afford to have a breakdown on the job
and not be able to finish the job so got
new tires they got new cutting edges
they got a full service and then as we
started that job I knew that we were
going to be able to well
have a better shot at getting the job
completed with that maintenance done and
so it's it's kind of an interesting
thing on the equipment that's older and
that it's paid for it's almost like
there's still payments on that equipment
you want to be putting money
away so
that when the time comes and you need
that new tires or new cutting edges or
whatever it might be that you've got the
money in the bank to service set
equipment and keep it running so it can
keep making you money we put new tires
on the grater and a lot of people said
that they're they're not aggressive
tires or they're not they're not knobby
enough part of the reason that I made
the decision on this tire and this tire
tread is that The Grater does a lot of
compaction on the road as it's traveling
back and forth compacting material and
these tires do a better job of
compacting and making it flat so I can
run this greater down on the road I can
crab walk and and offset the back from
the front just slightly and roll that
road with these tires and a great big
heavy duty tractor tire doesn't lay it
in as smooth as these do and they're
these are some really good tires they
came highly recommended so far uh I've
been impressed
[Music]
one of the things we're working on this
winter is clearing out this 5 acre piece
we've recently purchased this 5 1/2 acre
piece and our plan is to put up a barn
where we can put tools store equipment
and have a place to do some of that
maintenance whether it's regular
maintenance or annual maintenance
whatever it might be so we're clearing a
lot there's some some saw piles there's
some rock and gravel we've got a lot a
lot of cleanup to do typically we
wouldn't start a project like that like
like this right now but it's the weather
is warm there's no snow on the ground
and we can deal with a little bit of mud
the barn will let us take care and do
maintenance through the winter when we
have these slower times when we can't be
out building roads or working on other
projects so this is the start of
building a barn some of you might
recognize this property we we this this
5 and 1/2 acre piece is adjacent to the
40 acre piece where we've been
developing houses over the last couple
of
years really enjoy this area area we
like being close to town we like being
close to the highway it's I can get to
Starbucks in 3 minutes or Home Depot in
four um and so this area is really close
and and we've spent a lot of time out
here and really like this area so when
this
opportunity came to pick up an adjacent
parcel I I knew that I I wanted to jump
on it I had to have it I wanted to be
out here I really have had a great time
working on this development project the
last couple years um all of the parcels
have sold and there's houses
on I think I think there's foundations
on seven out of the eight
parcels and finished houses on half of
that and another by the end of next year
I my guess is that there'll be houses
built on every single parcel
[Music]
for